ich verlange dass wir nicht so hoch geht
das du dagegen schon ich spiele hier
überrumpeln willkommen war ein video
mir ist wahrscheinlich schon sehen ich
bin heute halte ich verspreche ich jetzt
zeit
ich bin heute in einer etwas anderen
räumlichkeit und zwar wo bin ich konnte
brach die kojoten hügel hier also leute
für uns gleich ab nach köln und wir
haben uns gedacht wir haben noch ein
zwei stündchen zeit und warum nutzen wir
diese zeit nicht intensiv denn wir auch
mega brocken video zu drehen und zwar
bin ich gerade bei mr 1
das kurier.at abgrund so weil darin ist
doch kultur pur ich bin sein leibwächter
falls jemand probleme durch
ich hab mir grad einfach mal meine haare
anders gefühlt ihr könnt ja mal sagen
jetzt findet so und wir haben uns
gedacht wir machen einfach so ein video
das ist halt 40 sohn witzige videos sind
bewegt sich also die beiden haben sich
einfach so wie viele fragen zehn fragen
oder so irgendwelche komischen fragen
perverse fragen lustige fragen intime
sex fragen ja ja und diese fragen werden
die mir jetzt gleich so von hinter der
kamera stellen und ich muss wirklich
schnell auf antworten und ich will gar
nicht lange lagern wird von sofort an
wenn ihr bock hab auch noch in thailand
wenn es euch gefällt dann langsam nach
oben da war jetzt gleich machen wir noch
auf seinem schimmel und zwar stelle ich
im dahl perverse intime fragen schon
folgst du also zeigt dass auch nachts
wieder auf jeden fall ab wir wollen
anfangen sofort an und fiel spät sein
recht attraktiv ich sehe irgendwie
erwachsener muss könnte ich fange
einfach an ok wat ihr habt aber das ist
jetzt nicht zu hart also es ist doch
sage ich habe mit der jüngsten bürger
und ich versuche wirklich jede frage mal
so schnell wie möglich zu beantworten so
dass es heute schnell durchgeht 105
sekunden smartphone
was sich schon fragen ausgesucht hast du
dir schon mal eine kerze die zahnpasta
tube oder ähnliches eingeführt mein
junge warum warum nicht darum einfach so
wahrheit aber ja ok aber warum warum
habt ihr was sind das für fragen weil es
sollte jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
schätzt man die kommentare was er für
nico ehrlich wie oft am tag seien
ständer
wann immer ich habe mir so auf mein
handy nicht ständig herunter
und immer wenn man einmal ein ständer
hat und man drauf und erzählte dass
woher soll ich das wissen weiß ich nicht
okay habt ihr auch irgendwas du
vielleicht wirst nicht so pervers 400
einfach lustig aber das heißt operation
oft einfach so trotzdem was anderes
vielleicht hast du die stets taka im
monat mit deiner hand sind das kann ich
gar nicht beantworten so bald es aber
doch schnell fand gar nicht du kannst du
dir gruppensex vorstellen also nur
vorstellen du musst jetzt machen so ob
du dir vorstellen kannst du der profis
ausnahmen da kann ich denn da ich auch
was hast du zuletzt gegessen hast du
geschmeckt ist es jetzt mal eine frage
die gestern abend ein käsesandwich das
mir sehr geschmeckt haben heute morgen
einen teller tors burg wie viele
personen sich schon kennen junge keine
ahnung man endlich wieder wenn das meine
mutter sieht natürlich aber das dock
perverse fragen ja trotzdem
alex hat schon mal einen orgasmus
vorgetäuscht
nein ja sicher wieso ich bin übrigens
mit meinen haaren finde ich wollte
liegen woanders bin voll zufrieden nur
meine seite müssen ihm noch gesagt also
seine seitenwände jetzt noch dings hier
also kurz kalt wird es folglich
ausgiebiger ssr als nebenberuflicher
kannst du ja aber ich fahre ich mich
jetzt nicht jammern ein das war meine
haare gleich kurz auch einfach spontan
allen seiten weißt du was willst du bei
dir ab was ich im kopf wenn er an diesen
gehört mal eigentlich cool oder also ich
habe das folgen machen weil da muss man
muss nicht zum friseur
nächste frage jetzt schnell also macht
kommt dann das video
hast du schon mal heim
einen ort gesucht wo schwule verkehr pro
series um mal zu gucken wer da so
speziell
weißt du was ich wollte also nicht extra
ich war letztens in ivica ivica city und
da ist uns wohl für lange wussten das
nicht mehr und wir gehen das so lang und
ein kollege von mir der hat die ganze
zeit so von irgendwelchen männern die
antworten seien eingegangen sind
also habe ich habe überhaupt nichts
gegen schwule aber das fand ich voll
witzig also hat es den kollegen ein mann
über alex hat sich schon mal selbst in
der muz körper ich hab kein bock mehr
ich wobei das ist nicht so ein niveau
los ist schon mal schwarz gefallen
damals ich wollte ehrlich schon drei mal
schwarzen teppich und habe insgesamt 100
euro dafür bezahlt was ist was war die
krasse beleidigen die du zu deiner
freundin gesagt hast hast du schon mal
einen trennten jung einfach so
angesprochen muss dazu gesagt nein habe
ich nicht angekreuzt durch dem er auf
mich also manchmal auch auf jungs aber
mehr auf mädchen weiß wie schnell das
etikett weil leute hier hat ja immer
weil immer wenn ich irgendwo hingehe
kommen so leicht an und sagen ey das von
you tube was machst du da allerdings hat
schon mal angst vater zu werden
ja man obwohl eigentlich nicht so also
das was mit diesem video ich habe
einfach keinen bock mehr auf diese
fragen an die hat nur scheiße ausgesucht
was euch gefallen hat dass nur noch um
da und wir machen jetzt meine haare neue
leute das sind wieder morgen auf meinem
channel ich würde sagen dass morgen ich
hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen wie
schon gesagt und checkt das video von
ihm ihr habt ihr mir schon fragen
stellen dann werden wir mal sehen welche
die die besten bestellt
mehr wollte ich nicht sagen abonniere
nicht vergessen als rein